six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to our next caller
from the eight one seven area code
caller from eight one seven go ahead
hello well I just really wanted to ask
have you heard of the g20 arrests that
took place on inauguration day I you
know it's been a while I remember a lot
of arrests on that day refresh my memory
what if you'd let me uh sure
well apparently what happened was
inauguration day protesters were kind of
restricted from going into zone to zone
well you know they they even had their
own throne well you know a protest zone
well you know and they they did their
own rally so on that rally the police
account is that they were followed very
closely and they were observed they were
observed breaking some windows here in
there yeah yeah you know and and they
waited what they did is they they swept
him up in a dragnet two hundred people
whoever was just happened to be in this
arbitrary location and I'm including
some journalists you know just in which
proves that they were just dragging it
whoever happened to be there and these
people are still facing charges of
conspiracy and whatnot not and the basis
for these prosecutions is not that they
are that they committed a crime if that
they were with somebody else who
happened to share a political view they
are and so since they wanted the Trump
administration they have been pushing to
criminalize dissent so hold on and let
me see if I can if I could just get a
question here just so I can understand
what you're saying oh please please just
saying that these people are being still
being legit litigation is still pending
against these people but not for any
crime but because of their political
beliefs like there's a there's on paper
somewhere it says that being prosecuted
because of their political beliefs they
are attempting to set new legal
precedents yes someone has been charged
they're like it says this person is
liberal so we're that we're charging
them what are they charging right yeah
yep he was he was he was there with
other people who just so happened to be
protesting Trump's point of view what
are they charged with like you need it
you need a crime you need something from
the Criminal Code to charge them with
right right
so what are they talking on it there
they're absolutely working on it and
this is this is huge but and these
people have been charged what have they
been charged with well no no they're
being held okay they're still in jail a
lot of them under way for even to be
held for a year and a half you need to
be told under suspicion of which crime
which crime are they being held on
suspicion of well yeah you know
conspiracy and all kinds of charges were
put later I mean it's hard that's not
that charges are they being held on well
as I think I've said already
you know charges of conspiracy things
like a sheet of all kinds of things and
of course you have vandalism but you
know each case is very nuanced but yeah
either way g20 okay I appreciate if
people are being held people are being
held because they knew someone that had
a political belief that that I want to
know about I will absolutely look into
that thank you for the call appreciate
it